[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire pour
débattre et discuter et réfléchir sur
des sujets d'actualité conseil de
quartier assemblée citoyenne groupe
action projet démocratie participative à
chaque ville son modèle de plus en plus
de communes créer des instances de
consultation de ses administrés
obligatoire pour les villes de plus de
80 mille habitants ses créations sont
facultatifs pour les autres alors
pourquoi certaines dunes donne la parole
de cette manière à leurs administrés ou
non pas avec nos invités joséphine
coleman berger bonsoir il en soit vous
êtes la mer deux plaisirs marie tooth et
un bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes adjointe au
maire de montigny le bretonneux vous
êtes délégué à la démocratie locale
année à ce mot linario bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes membre de l'assemblée
citoyenne dans le collège des
représentants de quartier à plaisir et
l'eau aiguille j'ai bon soir bon vous
êtes conseiller de quartier du village
du quartier de me conseiller du quartier
de visage d un des quartiers de
montigny-le-bretonneux excusez moi je
voudrais commencer avec vous madame
coleman verger à plaisir c'est une
assemblée citoyenne qui s'est créé vous
avez fait le choix de ne pas créer des
conseils de quartier mais m'a semblé
justement et en collège pourquoi ce
modèle là c'est un modèle qui me
semblent adaptées aujourd'hui je dirais
dans un concept de collectivités la
ville de plaisir et ricard thierry zay
et depuis de nombreuses années nous
essayons de rassembler les plaisirs rois
autour de toutes les actions communes de
la ville et nous semblait important de
créer une assemblée citoyenne qui puisse
rassembler l'ensemble des personnes de
la collectivité et non pas simplement
par quartier comme cet effet
précédemment puisque nous avons eu aussi
des conseils de quartier
particulièrement dans le quartier du val
hymne donc il nous a semblé important
d'avancer d'avoir
autre méthode peut-être de consultation
avec un déroulé et une organisation avec
des collèges et avec des personnes qui
seraient je dirais participantes puisque
c'était bien sûr volontaire de la part
des personnes de se présenter à cette
assemblée citoyenne que nous avons
inauguré on va dire il ya huit jours
après un travail de plusieurs mois
bien sûr de rencontres avec les
habitants intéressés par ce nouveau
projet alors pour créer cette assemblée
vous n'avez pas fait le choix du vote
des plaisirs ouais mais c'est ça a été
fait sur candidature avec une sélection
par vous même derrière pas uniquement
parce que c'est ça pourrait paraître je
dirais autoritariste ou bien un choix
politique je voudrais quand même
rappeler que cette assemblée citoyenne
aujourd'hui est en train de mettre en
place une charte de déontologie
également un règlement intérieur qui est
fait entièrement par l'assemblée
citoyenne justement pour qu'elle ne soit
pas politisée
pour qu'il y ait vraiment une liberté
totale d'ailleurs je ne siège pas cette
assemblée bien évidemment elle doit être
neutre elle doit être indépendante
donc les propositions et les
candidatures sont arrivées en mairie
bien sûr et il ya eu plusieurs personnes
dans des agents de la ville qui ont
regardé une envie de vouloir être à
l'intérieur de cette assemblée si toi
alors madame molinario tout à l'heure
nous expliquera un petit peu son rôle au
sein de cette assemblée
je voudrais qu'on parte un petit peu du
côté de montigny-le-bretonneux puisque
ça fait plus de vingt ans que les mini
montants ont la parole la ville elle
cette fois a fait le choix des conseils
de quartier marie touchant pourquoi
est-ce que vous gardez ce modèle
pourquoi ça perdure à
montigny-le-bretonneux déjà ça fait 30
ans que les pensées elles plus de trente
ans que les conseils de quartier à
montigné existe et pourquoi ce choix
parce que déjà ce cd sont des bénévoles
qui sont conseillers de quartier et qui
s'investissent par eux mêmes
c'est un choix délibéré de leur part
donc forcément si ça choix de leur part
c'est une volonté par la suite et ils
seront ils s'engagent ils ce sont des
élections dont il
il ya plusieurs conseillers de quartier
on a choisi les élections pour par les
habitants pour élire les membres du
conseil de quartier
nous avons à ce jour vie conseil de
quartier sur montigny le bretonneux
oui justement à montigny-le-bretonneux
c'est un voeu est ce que les gens les
habitants les imite un vote justement
alors cette année c'était dernier
exceptionnel parce qu'au vu du contexte
sanitaire nous n'avons pas pu maintenir
nos élections en présentiel
donc nous avons utilisé la plateforme
fuit city pour faire ces élections ces
élections elles ont eu lieu dont une
mairie par numérique et cette plateforme
que nous allons utiliser par la suite
parce que c'est une plateforme
participative et on va l'utiliser comme
guichet unique pour la concertation de
montigny-le-bretonneux
il y aura donc sur cette plateforme
plusieurs espaces dédiés entre autres un
espace pour chaque conseil de quartier
pour encourager les appel à idées pour
un autre pour le budget d'investissement
que nous avons choisi de mettre en place
durant ce mandat il y aura sur cette
plate forme également un espace dédié
pour les consultations comme les géants
gay est également un espace dédié pour
mettre en relation les bénévoles et les
associations
on parle de ses conseillers de quartier
ses représentants on a fait un peu de
choix ce soir aussi de donner à parle
principalement aux habitants loïc
vigiles vous êtes conseiller de quartier
pour le quartier du village de routine
bretonneux c'est tout récent c'est la
première fois vous êtes élu en octobre
dernier
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé à vous
lancer d'abord j'avais auparavant des
engagements explique notamment dans dans
le développement d'afrique et
j'ai souhaité justement laisser la place
aux africains parce que j'étais
président d'une association et trésorier
d'une ong internationales et donc en en
ne retirant j'avais toujours le sommet
de m'engager mais cette fatigue beaucoup
plus local mais je ne savais pas comment
à vrai dire et c'est finalement là que
vit ce qui s'est passé qui a provoqué
effectivement ce rapprochement a campé
du quartier car au sein de notre amour
au sein de notre j'irai pavillonnaire
qui est dans le quartier du village il
ya eu pendant la période du coc vite un
véritable élan de solidarité de partage
nous avons créé un groupe ouattara nous
avons pu faire preuve d'entraidé j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment très très bien entre
aussi nous avons fait preuve d'amitié on
a une occasion de se rencontrer en
respectant bien sûr la distanciation qui
était exigée à l'époque et c'est ainsi
qu'à des personnes de la résidence m'a
parlé du conseil de quartier
donc je me le suis a intéressé je
trouvais ça tout à fait pertinent en
termes d'engagement et donc j'ai
candidaté et j'ai le plaisir des yeux
voilà je me tourne maintenant vers
madame molinario puisque vous vous
représenter les habitants de plaisir
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé à vous
lancer dans cette nouvelle assemblée
citoyenne
vous savez quand on habite une grande
ville comme plaisir cas quand même plus
de 30000 habitants c'est pas très facile
de connaître les projets de l'équipe
municipale
donc il ya bien sûr le bulletin mensuel
de la ville de plaisir que je lis
attentivement mais je me sentais
toujours un petit peu à l'écart en fait
parce que on est au courant des projets
une fois christian en cours ou terminés
et mais du coup je me sens un peu à
l'écart et quand il ya eu cette
proposition de madame le maire avec son
équipe de faire cette assemblée
citoyenne je me suis dit que c'était la
bonne opportunité pour participer à la
vie de ma ville
d'abord c'est une façon de m'investir de
rester curieuse
de faire un petit peu ma part pour la
démocratie et surtout ce qui
m'intéressait dans ce projet
d'assemblées citoyennes c'est que ça
serait un vrai lieu de partager des
changes puisque c'est la politique et ça
me semblait vraiment primordial parce
que je pense qu'on peut effectivement
mettre un peu la politique de côté pour
faire avancer des projets pour notre
ville joséphine cole daisy pardon du
temps et puis et puis aussi dernière
chose pour ça vient de redonner un petit
peu de pouvoir aux citoyens
joseph une côte basse berger on l'entend
ils ont des idées ils sont là ils
veulent s'impliquer pour la vie de
consulter les différents collèges qui
font vivre plaisir ça peut permettre
aussi de découvrir des idées des
solutions auxquelles le conseil
municipal n'aurait pas pensé
indéniablement indéniablement on a bien
sûr une feuille de route avec avec que
nous avons mis en place lors de notre
campagne mais il est clair et pour cette
mandature
mais il est clair que au travers de
toutes les rencontres que nous faisions
déjà précédemment dans les quartiers
nous sommes rendus compte qu'il est
toujours très intéressant et très
important d'entendre la population il
peut nous échapper énormément de choses
même si les élus sont impliqués à juste
titre et avec conscience et engouement
mais nous nous avions déjà énormément de
rencontres mais des rencontres
spécifiques sur des projets alors que là
on est vraiment sur un travail qui me
semble un petit peu au co des skis qui
est qui était une qui est une
organisation qui travaille sur des
saisines sur des dossiers ce que ça peut
être des dossiers qui sont donnés par
les élus pour y réfléchir sur des grands
dossiers structurants de la ville mais
ça peut être aussi des dossiers que qui
vient directement
que l'assemblée citoyenne a envie de
travailler alors ensuite après ils
créent leur part commission toute
l'organisation interne de l'assemblée
est faite par les éléments par les
personnes elles-mêmes de l'assemblée
c'est absolument pas à madame le maire
et les élus qui organise l'intérieur de
cette absence vie citoyenne mais en tout
cas on attend beaucoup beaucoup de cette
assemblée citoyenne ci dessus marie
tooth à madame moule molinario à
prononcer le mot redonner un petit peu
de pouvoirs aux habitants mais justement
quel est ce pouvoir c'est seulement
consultatif est ce qu'il y aura comme à
plaisir on cloche des petites idées des
solutions aussi à montigny-le-bretonneux
effectivement la participation
démocratique à l'aide importante et les
idées elles vont émerger aussi par les
appel à idées nous avons mis en place
durant ce mandat nous allons mettre en
place un budget d'investissement donc un
appel à idées par les émirats pour les
habitants ce sont les habitants qui
donnerons nos idées sont les conseillers
de quartier qui est votre honte pour
l'heure où les projets qui concerneront
leur quartier nous allons également
mettre en place des balades urbaines en
présence de monsieur le maire
ce sont les conseillers de quartier qui
qui établissent un parcours est qui qui
seront sur le terrain pour avec monsieur
le maire vous regardez les jeux solo
avec vie j'ai justement alors là
convient de rendre les choses un petit
peu difficile mais pour représenter les
habitants comment vous allez faire pour
aller à leur rencontre est ce qu'il va y
avoir des réunions des réunions intime
ce zoom est ce qu'il y aura des petites
animations pour cette rencontre est
aussi peut-être des nouveaux voisins que
vous ne connaissez pas pour porter leur
parole auprès de la mairie
oui alors effectivement déjà dans le
quartier du village de hockey une
bretonne on est inquiet quand même
relativement bas qu il me fera quand
même difficile d'aller un peu partout
par contre qu'il paraît importante et
déjà de représenter une kpn qui viennent
de ce quartier mais pour lesquels déjà
j'ai pris pas mal de contacts avec les
différentes personnes qui sont autour de
moi qui est assez étonnant d'ailleurs et
ça contraste un peu c'est de bien
définir a fait manquer le rôle du
conseil de quartier parce que bien
souvent je reçois des personnes des
demandes de personnes qui ont pré plus
tôt je dirais à du fonctionnement de je
dirais de la voirie ou de de problème
entre voisins j'ai essayé d'expliquer
que quel pourrait être le rôle du comté
de quartier j'ai notamment marie tooth
pas peut-être me corrigera mais j'ai
surtout insisté sur le fait que nous
étions ici dans le cadre effectivement
deux à la fois je dirais d'améliorer
l'animation locale au sein du quartier
d'améliorer le cadre de vie en marie
tooth n'a évoqué effectivement les
balades de quartier qui permettent et si
ce temps de savoir si des problèmes si
on peut l'améliorer telle ou telle chose
par exemple des parcs de jeux ou ou tout
à fait autre chose on est un exemple à
ce sujet sur le parc de jeux le il ya
parc de jeux qui a été aménagé par la
mairie et ça a été fait avec le
précédent coup en concertation avec le
christ en compte et de cartes et je peux
vous dire aujourd'hui que ce parc de jeu
tel qu'il a été conçu à la fois donc
avec une initiative de la mairie mais je
dirais quand même bien avec une forte et
influente du concret de quartiers du
village
cet état des lieux est devenu un
véritable espace de rencontre et c'est à
vous dire pour revenir à votre question
ce sera pour moi l'occasion justement
d'aller dans le parc de jeu d'aller à la
rencontre des personnes et discute avec
elles pour justement voir quelle est
leur ticket lequel peut-être leurs
besoins en termes d'amélioration je
dirais en ce sens de l'animation locale
ou en termes je dirais d'amélioration du
cadre de vie agnès molinario scellé tout
début de l'assemblée citoyenne à
à plaisir on parler de règlement tout à
l'heure de chartes et l'inde aussi des
premiers dossiers sur lequel vous allez
travailler c'est le plan d'aménagement
et de développement durable comment est
ce que vous voyez ce premier travail est
ce qu'il ya aussi un peu d'inquiétude
sur des dossiers qu'on ne maîtrise pas
parce qu'on n'est pas agent municipal où
on n'est pas élu du conseil municipal
alors oui alors que vous vous disiez au
tout début
l'assemblée citoyenne et toute nouvelle
parce que elle n'a même pas huit jours
donc pour l'instant on en est vraiment à
a posé les bases
donc effectivement là pour l'instant je
me suis impliqué pour la charte et pour
le règlement intérieur
ensuite pour les autres dossiers c'est
une reconnaissance et c'est quand même
encore un peu flou mais j'ai bien cru
comprendre par l'intervention de madame
le maire la semaine dernière que d'abord
on sera aidé évidemment soutenue et que
on aura l'occasion de rencontrer
différents partenaires qu'ils soient
professionnels membres de la mairie pour
pouvoir compléter nos dossiers puis
ensuite discuté entre nous lors de la
commission citoyenne et éventuellement
faire des propositions qui seront
retournés évidemment vers madame le
maire et son équipe
mais c'est vrai que pour l'instant c'est
encore assez floue et on parle surtout
pour l'asseoir règlement intérieur sharp
et les dossiers vont venir j'en suis sûr
très vite je les filme comme un diverger
justement 1,7 hors essence et un encore
un petit bébé au sein du conseil ne suis
pas il ya un délégué à l'assemblée
citoyenne sébastien au regard j'espère
que je prononce bien son nom quel va
être son rôle quel est son rôle
justement à ceux à cet adjoint à ce
conseiller municipal
je pense que ça va être très similaire à
un montigny ça va être un peu le lien et
le liant entre entre cette assemblée
citoyenne pour être dans l écoute des
besoins et des difficultés peut-être
d'organisation mais aussi de faire le
lien avec la field les élus de façon à
ce que cette assemblée se sentent
complètement libre et bien sûr
indépendante dans ses propositions et
dans les actions pour proposer bien sûr
mais aussi
de ne pas se sentir seul comme disait
agnès molinario c'est à dire qu on les
lâche pas comme ça dans la nature
il est évident que ça doit être en
parallèle avec les choses que nous
faisons que nous avons déjà enclenché au
niveau de notre politique de cette
mandature
et puis surtout je dirais que sébastien
henry gagnaire et particulièrement une
personne est très à l'écouté très
disponible il en a déjà démontré toutes
ses facettes et ça c'est très important
il me fallait un adjoint veut dire
qu'ils soient à tout à fait présent dans
cette démarche et je rejoins ce que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure aussi surtout
tout ce qui y est présent sur le
territoire
il est évident que c'est le travail qui
leur est demandé c'est pas un travail
dans un bureau autour d'un dossier sont
des choses concrètes sur des espaces
publics où nous irons ensemble par
petits groupes qu'ils organiseront mm
sous forme de commission avec avec des
actions différentes bien sûr c'est
quelque chose de tonique et de dynamique
que nous voulons est pas du tout quel
que fût d'administratifs monsieur vie
j'ai soulevé aussi la question tout à
l'heure est-ce qu'il peut aussi avoir
des administrés qui ne font pas la part
des choses entre des représentants de
l'assemblée citoyenne et des conseillers
municipaux
s il faudra aussi peut être rappeler
quelques fois que ce sont des bénévoles
des habitants des membres socio
économique
ça va être votre lotion conseil
municipal de bien rappeler la part des
choses dodo la charte de déontologie on
écrit claire à ce sujet là il n'est pas
question d'utiliser cette assemblée
comme un lieu d'expression politique et
non plus je dirais un lieu pour aller
sur les réseaux pour par exemple
critiqué au monde censée quoi que ce
soit il doit y avoir une neutralité de
partage je pense que tout le monde l'a
déjà bien compris et je suis pas très
inquiète sur l'engagement des uns et des
autres vraiment pas monsieur viger je
vais terminer avec vous on a perdu
madame tout ça depuis quelques minutes
ce qu'on parlait tout à l'heure
au fond parlé tout à l'heure de monsieur
en guerre qui est en lien avec ce
assemblées citoyennes à plaisir madame
toussaint et l'adjointe déléguée à la
démocratie locale
quels sont les liens justement entre le
conseil municipal et vous en tant que
représentants de quartier ils viennent à
votre aide pour vous expliquer aussi
peut-être des ddd des consignes je n'ai
pas le mot administrative pour que vous
puissiez orienter correctement comment
se passe la relation avec le conseil
municipal aussi alors je vais profiter
que marie toussaint ne soit pas présente
pour justement où la reverdie parce que
quelqu'un qui effectivement d'abord très
présente auprès effectivement des
contrats de quartier g l à la sat
attention particulière de nos d'épaulé
de nos bd de nous conseiller
et surtout elle a une écoute je peux que
je peux qualifier d'extraordinaire des
toute personne exemplaire on la mettait
en termes d'écouté de contacts au niveau
je dirais de la démocratie locale et
aussi même je dirais d'animation locale
parce que elle est très attentive
notamment aux associations que local
donc en fait notre conseil de quartier
est un peu particulier les structurer
différemment de ce que j'ai compris de
l'organisation citoyenne à plaisir le
conseil de quartier est présidé par un
conseiller municipal qui est du quartier
d'ain en question et il y a des
conseillers municipaux de prescience du
quartier qui sont présents également
dans ce qu'on fait de quartier qui fait
que nous en gros je dirais nous
conseiller de quartier bénévoles élus
nous sommes peut même je dirais nous
avons notre expression cercle propre
mais nous sommes aussi épaulé par des
gens qui ont une expérience de
de la vie municipale et qui peut
effectivement nous avons mis en pétard
pas propre aux mines et en faire part
personne n'a pas d'éléments et de ne pas
nous recadrer mais nous permettrait
d'aller dans la bonne voie
donc voilà un groupement cela fonctionne
il ya quand même une indépendance de vue
très fort souligné en parlant en termes
de neutralité et que j'ai constaté en
tout cas aux femmes on comptait deux
quartiers une large une large diversité
de vue mais ce que j'ai surtout apprécié
nous sommes c'est qu'on fait de quartier
fait d' écoute mutuelle
le fait qu'on est toujours envie d'aller
vers la conjoncture est très peu de
compromis voilà je les ai vus acquiescé
madame coleman ce verger c'est vraiment
ça aussi c'est en plus on l'a dit la
copie d'un peu tout perturbé est ce que
finalement grâce à cette assemblée
citoyenne vous aurez peut-être plus de
remontées de vos administrés qui
n'oseraient peut-être pas aller dans les
services où ou les horaires de service
ne leur permet plus de se rendre sur
place
le rôle premier je pense de l'assemblée
citoyenne effective ainsi celui là c'est
d'avoir des gens implantées sur le
territoire qu'ils entendront les choses
peut-être différemment et la population
viendra peut-être plus facilement évoqué
certaines choses que ce soit négatif au
positif et c'est un vrai relais citoyens
qui me semble fondamental est donc
chassé la première démarche
et quand vous avez entendu madame
molinario tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est dans cet état d'esprit là que des
personnes viennent c'est d'être au
courant de ce qui se passe bien sûr même
s'ils ont commis les essais de
participer au premier chef et d'être aux
côtés des élus parce que les élus bas ce
sont des citoyens comme les autres
et donc si on peut avoir un rôle est
simple la relaie fluide
ben c'est tant mieux et c'est ce que
l'on souhaite et c'est ce que je
souhaite aussi vraiment je vous propose
qu'on termine sur ces mots merci à tous
les trois de vous être rendu disponible
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
monsieur vigie mada molinario vous êtes
donc les représentants des administrés
dave de vauville jusqu'en 2026 7
deux sociétés est maintenant terminé
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
temps d'échangé d'ici là prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]